so it's great to see you on the carpet
here tonight Liam for Game of Thrones
now of course we're looking forward to
seeing Davos back on the small screen
what advice would you give him for
future seasons at rezaian he's in a
world of heart with Stannis's knee and
unappreciative boss you know it's just
got to stick with it I mean as a
character Davos is a you know his his
loyalties is one of his best traits and
the fact that he does say and there is
good in Stannis and that he he feels a
great sense of responsibility and also
believes that for for Westeros that
Stannis is the best man for the job then
I think it's very important to get rid
of Melisandre first [ __ ] in in King's
Landing would not be a good thing but I
don't know what's gonna happen on that
front they haven't told me to be
continued now we've got lots of
characters who aren't as good as a boss
in Game of Thrones and one of them is
Joffrey and he's had some fantastic
moments hasn't here in the show
well it'll been your favorite moments
and Joffrey so far oh he's done some yet
listen it gets very difficult to say
your favorite moments because some of
them are truly disgusting
well as an actor I mean it's a complete
joy to play those kind of characters you
actually find yourself I've done a lot
of bad guys and you find yourself going
home in the evening all full of the joys
of spring and bringing flowers home and
chocolates and all sorts because you got
rid of the demons during the day uncheck
is the most sweet lovely kind of
character he's an absolutely gorgeous
gorgeous guy and very clever guy as well
and so well I mean it's it's a joy it
must be fabulous to be one of the most
hated men in the world the show with
their own reality TV show who would it
be why and what do you think it involved
oh I think the houndin are yeah that'll
be a fantastic TV show it'll be so much
better than carried a scenes with me
murder mayhem and you know animated
fantastic actress as well and so on you
know so is Rory and they'd be fantastic
to watch and they're on the road trip as
well you know so that wonderful thing
that there
doing who else who else who else I don't
know maybe Melisandre and Davos at home
in the kitchen
Melisandre with a nice apron on and that
was putting up a couple of shelves
fantastic
you